hello
um it's fun fun to be here
um
so the work I'm presenting today uh
title of it is attention approximates
Sports distributed memory
um and this was done in collaboration
with Genghis palavon
um and my PhD advisor is Gabriel Crimea
um so why should you care about this
work
um we show that the heuristic attention
operation can be implemented with simple
properties of high dimensional vectors
in a biologically plausible fashion uh
so the the Transformer and attention as
you know are incredibly powerful but
they were heuristically developed and
the softmax operation in attention is
particularly important but also
heuristic and so we show that the
intersection of hyperspheres that is
used in sports Studio memory uh closely
approximates the softmax and attention
more broadly both in theory and with
some experiments on train Transformers
uh so you can see sdn and supposed to
read memory
um as preempting attention by
approximately 30 years was developed
back in 1988
um and what's exciting about this is
that it meets a high bar for biological
possibility
um hopefully I have time to actually get
into the wiring of the cerebellum and
how you can map each operation to part
of the circuit there
so first I'm going to give an overview
of sports distributed memory
um then I I have a Transformer attention
summary but I assume that you guys
already know all of that we can like get
there and then decide how deep we want
to go into it
um I'll then talk about how actually
attention approximates STM
um interpret the Transformer more
broadly
um and then hopefully there's time to go
into sdm's biological possibility
um also I'm gonna like keep everything
high level visual intuition and then go
into the math
um but stop me and please ask questions
literally whenever
um okay
so uh sparse distributed memory is
motivated by the question of how the
brain can read and write memories
um in order to later retrieve the
correct one and some considerations that
it takes into account are high memory
capacity robustness to query noise
um biological possibility and some
notion of fault tolerance
um SDM is unique from other associative
memory models that you may be familiar
with like Hot Wheel networks
um in so much as it is it's sparse so it
operates on a very high dimensional
Vector space and the neurons that exist
in this space only occupy a very small
portion of possible locations
um it's also distributed so all read and
write operations apply to all nearby
neurons
um it is actually as a side note
um homfield networks if you're familiar
with them are a special case of Sparks
distributive memory I'm not going to go
deep into that now but
um I have a blog post on it
um okay so first we're going to look at
the right operation for super memory
um we're in this High dimensional uh
binary Vector space uh we're using
Hammond distance as our metric for now
we'll move to continue this later
um and we have this green pattern uh
which is represented by the solid Dot
and the hollow circles are the symptoms
um also think of everything like quite
abstractly and then we'll map to biology
later
um so this pattern has a red radius
which is some heavy distance
um it activates all of the neurons
within that Heming distance
and then it's uh here I just denote that
each of those neurons are now storing
that green pattern and the green pattern
has disappeared so I'm keeping track of
its location with this kind of fuzzy
Hollow Circle that'll be relevant later
so we're writing in another pattern this
orange one
and note here that neurons can store
multiple patterns inside of them uh and
formally this is actually a
superposition or just a summation of
these high dimensional vectors because
they're high dimensional you don't have
that much so you can get away with that
but for now you can even just think of
it as like as a neuron can store
multiple patterns
um finally we have a third pattern this
blue one we're writing it in another
location
and yeah so again you can we're keeping
track of the original pattern locations
and they can be but they can be
triangulated from the nearby neurons
that are storing them
and so we've written in three patterns
now we want to read from the system so I
have this pink star side uh it appears
it has a different um it's represented
by a given Vector which is has a
specifications of space and I'm making
sure again
um but now the neurons
um output the patterns that they've
stored previously and so you can see
that depend based upon its location it's
getting four blue patterns uh two orange
and one green
um and it then does a majority rule
operation where it updates towards
whatever pattern it's seen from us so in
this case because um Hulu was actually a
majority it's just been an update
completely towards blue again I'll
formalize this more in a bit but um this
is really to give you intuition for the
core operations of sem
so the the key thing to relate this back
to attention is actually to abstract the
way the neurons that are operating under
the hood and just consider the circle
intersection and so what each of these
intersections between the uh Pink lead
circles and each of the right circle of
means is is
the neurons that both store that pattern
that was written in and are now being
read from by the query and the size of
that intersection
um corresponds to how many patterns the
query is then going to read
and so formally we Define the number of
neurons in this circle intersection as
the cardinality between number of
neurons and pattern number of neurons in
query and there are sections
okay are there any questions like at a
high level before I get more into the
math
I don't know if I can check is it easy
for me to check Zoom nah sorry Zoom
people I'm not going to check
um okay but the neurons is randomly
distributed yes yeah yeah
um and there's later there's more recent
work that uh they can learn and update
their location to cut tile manifold but
uh in this you can assume that they're
randomly initialized binary High
dimensional vectors
um okay so this is the full SDM uh
update rule
um I'm gonna break it down
so the first thing that you do so so
this is this is for reading to be clear
so you've already written patterns into
your neurons
um so the first thing you do is you
weight each pattern by the size of its
Circle intersection so
the circle intersection there for each
pattern
then you sum over all of the patterns
that have been written into this space
so you're just doing a weighted
summation of them
and then there's this uh normalization
by the uh total number of intersections
that you have
and finally because at least for now
we're working in this binary space uh
you map back to Binary just seeing if
any if the values are greater than a
half
um okay how familiar are people with
attention I looked at like the previous
talks you had they seem quite high level
like can you guys write the attention
equation for me is that like
can I get thumbs up if you can do that
yeah okay I'm not like oh oh I'll go
through this um but I'll probably go
through it faster than otherwise
um so when I first made this
presentation like this was the state of
the Art for Transformers which was like
and so it's kind of funny like how far
things have come now I don't need to
tell you that Transformers are important
um
so
yeah I'm going to work with this example
well well okay I'm going to work with
this example here the cat sat on the
blank
um and so we're in this setting we're
predicting the next token
um which the word math
um and so there are kind of four things
the attention operation is doing uh the
first one up here is it's generating
what are called keys values and queries
and again I'll get over the map in a
second I'm just trying to keep it high
level first
um and then we're going to compare our
query with each of the keys so the word
the Which is closest to the word we're
next predicting is our is our query and
we're seeing how similar it is each of
the uh key vectors
um we then based upon that similarity do
this uh softmax normalization so that
all of the uh attention weights so on
the one uh and then we sum together
their value vectors to use to propagate
to like the next layer or uses our
prediction
and so at a high level you can think of
this as like the query word the is
looking for nouns and their Associated
verbs and so hypothetically it has a
high similarity with words like cat and
sat or their keys
um so this then gives large weight to
the cat and sat value vectors uh which
get moved to the next part of the
network
um and the uh cat value Vector
hypothetically contains a superposition
of other animals like mice and maybe
words that rhyme with Matt and so uh and
the SAT Vector also contains things that
are sat on including that and so uh what
what you actually get from the value
vectors of paying attention to cat and
sat are um like three times mat plus one
times Mouse plus one time sofa this is
again like a totally hypothetical
example but
um I'm trying to make the point that you
can extract from your value vectors uh
things useful for predicting the next
token
um by paying attention specific keys
um
so and and I guess yeah another thing
here is like what you pay attention to
so cat and Stat might be different from
what you're actually extracting if
you're paying attention to your keys but
you're getting your value vectors out
um okay so here is the full attention
equation the the top line I'm separating
out the projector matrices uh W
subscript V A and Q and in the second
one I just collapse them and then
selected new Lac
um and
yeah so breaking this apart the first
step here is We compare we do a DOT
product between our query vector and our
keys
um this should actually be a small you
know
um and so yeah we're doing this dot
product between them to see get a notion
of similarity
um we then apply the softmax operation
which is an exponential over a sum of
exponentials
um the way to think of the stop Max is
it just makes
um large values larger and and this will
be important for the relation to SCM so
I'll spend a minute on it
um at the top here I have like some
hypothetical items indexed from uh zero
to nine and then the like values for
each of those items in the second row I
just do like a normal normalization of
them and so the top item goes to 30
value but if I instead do a stop map so
it depends on the medical condition the
soft Max but uh the value becomes 0.6 so
it just it makes you your distributions
Peak here is kind of one way of thinking
of it and and this is useful for
attention because you only want to pay
attention to the most important things
or the things that are nearby and kind
of ignore stuff further away
and so once we've applied our softmax
um we then uh just do a weighted
summation of our value vectors
which actually get extracted
um and propagate to the next layer
um okay so here's the the full equation
um I went through that a little bit
quickly I'm happy to answer questions on
it but I think half of you know it half
of you don't
um
okay
so how does Transformer attention
approximate sparse distributed memory
this 30 year old thing that I've said is
biologically plausible
um
so yeah
is five years ago uh I think the
attention equation I'm showing here was
developed I mean attention is all you
need was the highlight but benjio has a
paper from 2015.
where it was actually first written in
this way
correct me if I'm wrong but I'm pretty
sure yeah I mean I guess like this
particular one that's why I was asking
the question because like no it's a good
question that like two different methods
that could be classified as like
attention proposal is great for like the
same and like be selfish of it like one
of them that's like uh
yes exactly so I'll show that SDM has
really nice mappings to a circuit and a
cerebellum at the neural level
um and and then there's right now it's
this link to attention
um and I guess you you make a good point
that there are other attention
mechanisms this is the one that has been
dominant
um but I don't think that's just a
coincidence like there's been a bunch of
computing yourself Max is expensive and
there's been a bunch of work like the
linformer et cetera et cetera that tries
to get rid of the soft Max operation and
it's just done really badly
um like there's a bunch of jokes on
Twitter now that it's like a black hole
for people that like try and get rid of
softmax and you can't
um and so it seems like this and like
other versions of it Transformers just
don't scale as well in the same way and
so there's something important about
this particular attention equation
um
so the the thing that I think is
important is that you have this
exponential weighting uh where you're
really paying attention to the things
that matter and you're ignoring
everything else
um and that is what SDM approximates
um there might be equations but the the
point I was just trying to make there is
like the softmax does seem to be
important and this equation does seem to
be very successful
um and we haven't come up with better
formulations for
yeah no it's a great question
um okay so it turns out that sparse
distributed memory uh as you move your
query and your pattern away from each
other so you pull these these circles
apart they'll read and write circles the
number of neurons that are in this
intersection in a sufficiently high
dimensional space the K is approximately
exponentially and so on this right plot
here I'm pulling apart the x-axis is
pulling apart the blue and the green
circles and the y-axis is uh on a log
scale the number of neurons that are in
the intersection and so to the extent
that this is the linear plot on a log
scale it's exponential
um
and and this is for a particular setting
where I have my I have 64 dimensional
vectors which is like used in gdp2
um it it holds across a lot of different
settings particularly higher Dimensions
uh which are now used for bigger
Transformers
um okay so I have this shorthand for the
circle intersection equation
um and what I'll show is how the circle
intersection is approximately
exponential
um so we can invite a two constant C so
if you're one it's like you have two
um with the the one outside because
you're normalizing softmax is
exponential over some extenticals that
will cancel the thing that matters is C2
and you can approximate that nicely with
the beta coefficient that's used in the
softmax
um
and so yeah I guess as well I'll Focus
first on the binary original version of
sem
um but then we also develop a continuous
version
um
okay so yeah the the two things that you
need for the circle intersection
um and the exponential decay to work are
you need to map it to attention is you
need some notion of a continuous space
and so you can use this equation here to
map handing distances
um to discretize proton similarity
values
um where the hats over the vectors are
are L2 normalizations
um and you can then write the circle
intersection equation on the left
um as this exponential with these these
two concepts that you need to learn and
and then rewrite this by converting C2
and C you can write this in the data
coefficient
um let me get to some plots
um yeah so so you need the correct
coefficient but you can fit this with a
log linear regression in a closed form
um
I want to show a plot here
yeah okay so uh and the blue is our
Circle intersection for two different
ending distances both using 54
dimensional vectors
um and the Orange is our actual softmax
detention operation where we fit the
beta coefficient so that it will it will
the hammock distance used by attention
is equivalent to the heaviest infused by
SDM
um and you can see so that the main plot
is uh the normalized weights so this
um summed up and undivided system one
and then I block blocks here
um and you can see that in not log space
the curves agree quite nicely uh you can
see that for the higher dimensional uh
sorry the larger heavy distance the long
plot you see this uh drop off here over
the circle intersection stops being
exponential uh but it turns out this
actually isn't a problem because the
point at which the drop the uh
exponential breaks down you're at
approximately 0.20 here and you're
basically paying negligible attention to
any of those points and so in the regime
where the exponential really matters uh
this approximation holds true
um yeah
yeah
yeah yeah no I I just wanted to actually
like show up in here to get some
question
um before yeah
um
so all we're doing here is we're just
we're in a binary space with original
velocity um and we're just using this
similarity
um and then what you need to do is just
have the beta book and you can view your
beta coefficient and attention that's
determining how geeky things are and
this relates directly to the having the
sense of your um circles that you're
using for me to write on version
and so yeah to like mathematically show
this now on this slide I'm not using any
tricks I'm just rewriting attention
using the sem notation of patterns and
players
um so this little box down here is is
doing that nothing
and this is the money slide where we're
updating our query
and on the left we have our extension
equation written in SEO notation uh we
expand our top hacks and then the the
main statement is this is closely
approximated by if we swap out our
exponential with the sem sort of order
section equation
foreign
so and again the two things that you
need for this to work are one your
attention vectors your um keys and
queries need to be able to mobilized so
I got hats on them
um and then you want
if you decide if they're going to panic
distance for SCM and I'll get into what
having distance are good for different
things
um then you need to have a beta
coefficient that relates to it
but again that's just how many things
are you trying to pay attention to
um
so yeah just as a quick side note
um you can write sdn using continuous
vectors and then not need this mapping
to cosine similarity
um
and so here I have the plots again but
with this and
um I've added the
the orange of the Granite splits what
I've added the continuous approximation
here too
um
and what's nice about the continuous
version is you can actually then write
sparse distributed memory as a
multi-layered perceptron with slightly
different assumptions
um and I'm not going to talk about that
now but
um this is featured in as far as three
memory is a continual learner which is
uh it was added to the additional
readings and it'll be in um sorry this
shouldn't say icml it should say iClear
um
it was it's just been accepted to like
there for this year
um okay so do trained Transformers use
these beta coefficients that I've said
are similar to those for SDI
um and so
it shouldn't be surprising that
depending on the how many distance
you've set SCM is better for certain
things
um for example
um you just want to store as many
memories as possible and you're assuming
that your queries aren't noisy or um you
you're assuming your queries are really
noisy so you can't store as much but you
can retrieve from a long distance
um and if attention to the Transformer
is implementing sparse distributed
memory we should expect to see that the
beta coefficients that the Transformer
uses correspond to these good instances
of STM and so we have some weak evidence
that that's the case
um so this is the key query normalized
variant of attention where you actually
learn your beta coefficient normally in
Transformers you don't
um but you don't LG Norm your vectors
and so you can kind of have this like
effective beta coefficient so in this
case it's the cleaner instance where
we're actually learning beta and this
one's um trended on a number of
different translation tasks we take the
learner benefit coefficients across
layers and across
three different Notions of sports
distributed memory that are optimal for
different things
and again this is weak evidence in so
much is to derive the optimal fcm beta
coefficients or corresponding handing
distances we need to assume uh random
patterns in this High dimensional space
and like obviously real world data isn't
random
um however it is nice to see one all the
beta coefficients fall within the bounds
and two they skew towards the max very
noise
um which makes more sense if you're
dealing with like complicated real world
where the next data points you see might
be out of distribution based what you've
seen in the past
um the max memory capacity variant
assumes no query noise at all and so
it's like how many things can I pack in
assuming that my the the questions I'm
asking the system are are perfectly
formed
um
okay
um just talking a little bit about
Transformer components more broadly
um
so I've mentioned that you can write the
feed forward layer as a version of SDM
that has like a sort of notion of longer
term memory
um there's also layer Norm which is
crucial in Transformers
um and it's not quite the same but it
can be related to the L2 normalization
that's required by SDM there's also the
key query normalization variant that
explicitly does this helps you
normalization and it does get slightly
better performance at least on the small
test that they did
um I don't know if this would scale to
larger models
um
and so I guess this work is interesting
and so much as like the biological
possibility which I'm about to get to
and then the the links to Transformers
it hasn't to date improved Transformer
architectures but that doesn't mean that
this lens couldn't be used or be useful
in some way
um so yeah I list a few other way things
that SDM is related to that could be
used to funnel in and actually in the
the new work where SDM is a continual
learner we kind of expand the cerebellar
Circuit look at components of it
particularly inhibitory interneurons
Implement those in a deep learning model
and it then becomes much better at
continual learning so that was kind of a
fun way of actually using this link to
get better bottom line performance
um okay so a summary of this section uh
is basically just the intersection
between two hyperspheres uh approximates
an exponential
um and this allows sdm's read and write
operations to approximate attention both
in theory and our limited tests
um and so kind of like big picture
research questions that could come out
of this is uh first is the Transformer
so successful because it's performing
some key cognitive operation
um the cerebellum is a very old brain
region used by most organisms including
fruit flies
um maybe even cephalopods through like
Divergent but now convergent evolution
um and then given that the Transformer
has been so successful empirically is
SDM actually the correct theory for
cerebellar function
um and that's still an open question
um
as we learn more and more about the
cerebellum there's nothing that yet
disproves SDM as as working there and I
think it's I'll go out on a limb and say
it's like one of the more compelling
theories for how this error button is
actually working
um
yeah and so I think this this work kind
of motivates looking at more of these
questions both of these questions are
more seriously
um okay
do we have do we have time
cool
um so here's the circuit that implements
hastion
um at the bottom we have patterns coming
in for either reading or writing
and they're gonna actually I break down
each of these slides
okay yeah so so first we have patterns
that come in and every neuron here these
are the dendrites of each neuron and
they're deciding whether or not they're
going to fire for the input that comes
in
then if the neuron does fire and you're
writing in that pattern then you
simultaneously and I'm going to explain
this is crazy the brain doesn't do this
and I'm going to hopefully take it on
um you not only need to have the main
but the pattern that um activates no
problems but you need to have a separate
line that tells the normal to soar and
just like you have this difference
between keys and values where they can
be different vectors representing
different things here you can have a key
that comes in and tells a neuron when to
activate and the value for what it
should actually like soar this is called
a hetero associative mapping
um
and then once you're reading from the
system
you also have your query come in here
activate neurons and those neurons then
output whatever they stored and the
neurons Vector is is this a particular
column that's it's stored and it's that
reminder as a reminder it's storing
patterns in super conception
um and then it will dump whatever it's
stored across these out what lines
and then you have this G
um majority bit operation to converts to
a zero one decided the neuron is going
to fire or not
um and so
here is the same circuit but where I
overlay uh cell types
um and so
I'll come back to this slide because
most people probably aren't familiar
with cerebellar circuitry
um let me just
get some water
um okay so the way that the cerebellum
is um pretty homogeneous and then it
follows the pattern throughout
um also fun fact 70 of all neurons in
the brain are in the cervo
um they're small so you wouldn't know it
but the cerebellum's like very
underappreciated and there's a bunch of
evidence and it has a closed loop
systems with most higher order
um processing now if your cerebellum is
damaged you are more likely to have
autism
etc etc so it does a lot more than just
fine motor coordination uh which a lot
of people have like assumed in the past
um okay so inputs come into the muscle
fibers here they interface with granular
cells this is a major up production
where you have tons and tons of random
cells
each Rhino cell has what are called
parallel fibers which is incredibly long
and thin Maxwells that Branch out in
this T structure
and then they they're hit by the
purkinje cells which will receive up to
a hundred thousand parallel fiber inputs
it's the highest connectivity of any
neuron brain
um and then the purkinje cell will
decide whether or not fire and send its
output downwards here
so that's the whole uh system where
patterns come in and around Society they
find it or not and the way that they
then output they're out
you then have a separate right line
which is the climate virus so the
climbing Fighters come up and they're
pretty amazing in that these connections
here you can have in order they're not
as important the one that really matters
is that they're not very strong either
but what it really matters is it goes up
and it wraps around individual profanity
cells and the mapping is close to one to
one
um between climbing fibers and potential
cells at least a very strong Action
potentials and so an air connections
here is uh as in the stuff off the side
yeah right with these two alignments
they're connecting two arms oh so
they're separate neurons coming from in
separate areas
um particular calls here go into Deep
Cell relatively I kind of when the
coreless are on and that then feeds into
um Thalamus like back to higher order
brain regions or like Jonathan mustard
muscle movement Etc
um a lot of people think of the
cerebellum is kind of like a fine-tuning
lookup table where like you've already
decided the muscle movement you want to
do but the cerebellum will then like do
a bunch of adjustment adjustments so
that's like much more accurate
um but it seems like this also applies
to like next word prediction like we
have fmri data for this a neuroscientist
once that's made like a dirty little
secret of fmri is that uh the Starbomb
lights up for everything
um so okay
um
going back to this circuit here then
um yeah time scales are these operating
at I mean how long is the information
stored and retrieved to be have any idea
about this
um like it's just like a couple of
milliseconds or like consideration more
persistent so the main theory is that
you have updating through
um uh time to pass dependent plasticity
where your climbing fiber will either
which is doing the what you want to
write in will fire either just before or
just after uh your rhino cell spider
um and so that then updates the
prevention cell finances for long-term
depression
um so whatever time scale that's
happening on the quality fiber makes
very large potentials
um or it leads to very large
and so I do think you could get a pretty
fast scientific updates and they're also
persistent for a long time
um I think so yeah it's Finance it can
stay for like the rest of your life yeah
so what's really unique about this
circuit is the fact that you have these
two orthogonal uh inputs where you have
the muscle fibers bringing information
in to the side of the neurons on fire or
not but then the totally separate
chronic fiber lines that can update
specific neurons
um and what they're storing and will
later outline and then the Protege cell
is is so important that's kind of doing
this cooling across every single neuron
and each neuron remember it's storing a
vector this way and so the purkinje cell
is doing element-wise summation and then
deciding whether it fires or not and
this allows for you to store your
vectors in superposition and then later
denoise them
this this all this the theory that's the
only Maps quite well to the um more and
all those theories of solar power
function which are still quite dominant
if anyone's familiarism
neuron and the SDM you're introduced
before each neurons
okay
um and then yeah so the the location of
the neuron those Hollow circles
corresponds to the graduates of
dendrites here
where the patterns that pop in
correspond to the activations of
modifiers and then the uh efforts
um postsynaptic connections are with
deeper into zone so that's actually it's
what it's storing is in the synaptic
connections with the ending cells at
that interface
and then the purkinje cell does the
majority bit operation inside of
velocifier or not
yeah yeah
I think we're basically into into
question time so yeah thanks a lot
of anything about this meeting but it
seems as other students for a long time
and uh I am curious what's your
hypothesis or what we should be doing
for sure development really
because it seems that
so if you have this link of Transformers
yeah I think long-term memory yeah well
that's good for a short-term memory
because for me it seems like we are
doing this in the prompt context right
now but how could we incorporate these
together
yeah yeah so this work actually focuses
more on the short-term memory oh where
it relates to the attention operation
um but you can rewrite SDM it's almost
more natural to interpret it as a multi
perceptron that does like a soft Max
activation across its or a top pay
activation across its um neurons it's
like a little bit more complicated than
that but
um
yeah so so the the yeah the most
interesting thing here is the fact that
like I just have a bunch of neurons and
in activating nearby neurons in this
title control space you get this
exponential weighting which is the soft
mass and then because it's an Associated
memory where like you have keys and
values it is attention
um and yeah I guess like the the thing I
most want to drive home from this is
like it's actually surprisingly easy for
the brain to implement the attention
operation the attention operation
um just using High Dimensions vectors
and activating
so it's good for short-term money
um yes if you were if you were actually
use sem for attention
um yeah so let me go all the way back
real quick this is important there are
kind of two ways of viewing SDM and I
don't think you were here for the talk I
think I saw you come in a bit later
which is totally fine but I was uh
oh cool cool yeah yeah okay so so there
are two ways of looking at sem there's
the neuron perspective
which is this one here
um and this is actually what's going on
in the very important
um and so the only thing that
interactive concept is the neurons the
patterns are a funnel
um and then there's the pattern-based
perspective which is actually what
attention is doing
and so here you're abstracting away the
neurons we're assuming they're operating
under the hood but what you're actually
Computing is the distance between the
true location of your pattern and
aquarium and there are pros and cons to
both of these the pro to this is you get
much higher Fidelity
um distances but you know exactly how
far the query is from the original
patterns
um and that's really important when
you're deciding what to update for it
like you really want to make know like
what is closest and what is further away
and be able to apply the exponential
weighting correctly
um the problem is you need to store all
of your pattern notifications in memory
and so this is why Transformers have
like limited context Windows
um the other perspective is this
long-term memory one where you forget
about the patterns and you just look at
where uh you just have your neurons that
store a bunch of patterns and another is
an organ superposition and so you can't
really you can tiny like when people
compiler was like not funny that it's
all much noisier but you can store tons
of patterns and you're not concerned by
contacts or you can think of any penalty
layer a story like the entire data set
in a noisy superposition of States
um
yeah hopefully that kind of answers your
question
I think there's one here at first yeah
um
so I guess my question is like uh so I
guess like we've been kind of Ensure
them that like the uh modern like
self-attention method is um it's like uh
SPM mechanism that like seems possible
it might look like the modern
contemporary like theories of like how
the brain is definitely SEO and I guess
my question is like
um to what degree is that like that like
it's originally verified versus like you
were like mentioning earlier that like
it might actually be easier to have done
this using like an MLP layer in some
sense then like
yeah
and so like how to experimentalists like
actually distinguishing and meeting pet
offices yeah like for instance like one
thing that like I wasn't incredibly
clear about it's like like
even it's like
two attention or like SEO like that
doesn't actually mean it would because
like maybe it can't be back up yeah
um so like
how does this like get actually tested
totally yeah yeah so uh on the back prop
Point
um
you wouldn't have to do it here because
you have the climbing fibers that can
directly like give drainage signals
um to like what the neurons can store
um so so in this case you
it's like a supervised learning task
where the funny partner knows what it
wants to write in or like how it should
be opted in the prefinity cell synapses
um but for your broader Point
um you basically need to do to test this
you need to be able to do
um real-time learning
um the drosophila mushroom body is
basically identical to the cerebellum
um and the Fly I mean brain data set has
done most of the individual neuron
connectivity but what you would really
want to do is like any vitro real time
um super like um
super super high frames per seconds
um calcium Imaging
um and be able to see how sinuses change
over time and and so for an associative
learning task like
um hear a sound move left hear another
sound move right or smells or whatever
um present one of those
um Trace like figure out the small
subset of neurons that fire which we
know is a small subset so that already
picks up
um see how the synapses here update and
how the outputs of it correspond to
changes in motor action
um and then extinguish that number so
write in a new one and then watch it
watch it go away again
um and like our cameras are getting fast
enough and like our calcium and like
voltage indicators are getting to be
really good so hopefully in the next
like three to five years we can do some
of those tests
um but I think that would be very
definitive
yeah
yeah do we have any other questions I
think there was one more and then I
should
yeah so uh I wouldn't get confused with
multi-headed events
um because that's different attention
heads all doing their own attention
operation it's funny though the servo
has micro zones which you can think of
as like separate attention heads in a
way I don't want to take that analogy
too far in life but but it is it is
someone interesting
um so the way you relate this is
um
inattention you have your beta
coefficient
um that is an effective data coefficient
because the vector Norms of your keys
and queries aren't constrained
um that corresponds to a Heming distance
and here that corresponds to the number
of neurons that are on for any given
input
um and the heavy distance you want I had
that slide before
um depending instances you want depends
upon what you're actually trying to do
um and if you're not trying to store
that many memories for example you have
a higher ending distance because you can
get a higher Fidelity calculation for
the number of neurons in that noisy
intersection
um yeah
cool yeah thanks a lot excellence
so as a disclaimer uh
so as a disclaimer uh before I introduce
your next speaker uh the person was
scheduled unfortunately the cat and sold
last minute due to faculty interviews so
our next speaker has very graciously
agreed to present at the very last
minute
um but we are very grateful to him so
I'd like to introduce everybody to will
so will is a computational neuroscience
machine learning PhD student at the
University College of London at their
Gatsby unit so I don't know if anybody
has heard about the Gatsby unit I'm a
bit of a history buff or a history nerd
depending on how you phrase it the
Gatsby unit was actually this incredible
Powerhouse in the 1990s and 2000s so
Hinton used to be there Zubin garamana
used to be there he's now in charge of
Google research
um I think they've done a tremendous
amount of good work
um anyways and and now I'd like to
invite will to talk about how to build a
cognitive map
uh did you want to share your screen
yeah okay um can you stand in front of
here let me stop sharing
okay
uh so I'm gonna be presenting this uh
what it's a it's all about how a model
that people in the group that I work
with uh to study the hippocampalendarino
system uh completely independently uh
turned out to look a bit like a
Transformer so that's this paper that
I'm going to talk about is describing
that link and so the paper that built
builds this link is by these three
people uh James is a postdoc half at
Stanford uh Sims a professor at Oxford
and in London and Jose a PhD student in
London so
uh so this is the problem that uh the
the this model of the hippocampus Rhino
system which we'll talk more about uh is
supposed to solve it's basically the
observation there's a lot of structure
in the world and generally we should use
it in order to generalize quickly
between tasks it's the kind of thing I
mean by that is you know how 2D space
works because of your long experience
living in the world and so if you start
at this greenhouse and step North it's
orange one and so there's red ones
there's the pink one because of the
structural 2D space
you can think to yourself oh what will
happen if I step left and you know that
you'll end up back at the green one
because Loops of this type close in 2D
space okay and uh this is you know
perhaps this is a new city you've just
arrived in this is like a zero shop
generalization because you uh somehow
realize that the structure applies more
broadly and use it in a new context
uh yeah and there's generally a lot of
these kinds of situations where there's
structures that like reappear in the
world so I mean lots of instances where
the same structure will be useful to
doing these like zero shot
generalizations uh to predict what
you're going to see next
okay
and so uh you may be able to see how
we're already going to start mapping
this onto some kind of sequence
prediction task that feels a bit
transform-esque which is you receive
this sequence of like uh observations
and in this case actions movements in
space and your job is given a new action
step left here you have to try and
predict what you're going to fit so
that's a kind of sequence prediction
version
the way we're going to try and solve
this is based on factorization it's like
you can't go into one environment and
just learn from the experiences in that
one environment you have to separate out
the structure and the experiences you're
having so that you can reuse the
structural part which appears very often
in the world
okay and so yeah separating memories
from structure and so you know here's
our separation of the two we have our
dude wandering around this like uh 2D
grid world and uh you want to separate
out the fact that there's 2D space and
it's 2D space that has these rules
underlying it and in a particular
instance in the environment you're in
you need to be able to recall which
objects are at which locations in the
environment
okay so in this case it's like oh this
position has an orange house this
position that's green sorry orange uh
red and pink and so you have to bind
those two you have to be like whenever
you realize that you're back in this
position recall that that is the
observation you're going to see that
okay and so this model that the
um we're gonna build is some model that
tries to achieve this
uh yeah new stuff and so when you enter
it imagine you enter a new environment
with the same structure you wander
around and realize it's the same
structure all you have to do is bind the
new things that you see to the locations
and then you're done passed up you know
you know how to work work
uh so this is what a neuroscientists
mean by a cognitive map is this idea of
like separating it out and understanding
the structure that you can reuse in new
situations and uh yeah this model that
uh the was built in the lab uh is a
model of this process happening of the
separation between the two of them and
how you use them to do your inferences
and this is the uh bit that it's
supposed to look like in transform so
it's a general introduction and then
we'll dive into it a little more now
make sense over the broad picture
good
silence I'll assume is good
so we'll start off with some brain stuff
uh so there's a long stream of evidence
from spatial navigation but the brain is
doing something like this I mean I think
you can probably imagine how yourself
you yourself are doing this
um already when you go to a new city or
you're like trying to understand a new
task that has instructions you
recognized from previously you can see
how this is something you're probably
doing but spatial navigation is an area
in Neuroscience which had like a huge
stream of discoveries over the last like
50 years
um and a lot of evidence of the neural
basis of this computation so we're going
to talk through some of those examples
the earliest of these are psychologists
like uh Tolman who were showing that
rats in this case can do this kind of
path integration structure so the way
this work is they got put at a start
position here down at the bottom s and
they got trained but this route up here
got your reward so this is The Maze We
had to run around uh then they were
asked they were put in this new uh this
the same thing but they blocked off this
path that takes this long-winding route
and given instead a selection of all
these arms to go down and they look at
which path the rat goes down and the
finding is that the rat goes down the
one that corresponds to heading off in
this direction so the rat has somehow
not just learned like a you know one
option of this is like blind
memorization of action that I need to
take in order to root around instead no
it's learning actually that the struck
in embedding the reward and its
understanding of 2D space and taking a
direct route there even though it's
never taken it before there's evidence
that rats are doing this as well as us
and then a series of like neural
discoveries about the basis of this so
uh John O'Keefe
um stuck an electrode in the hippocampus
which is a brain area we'll talk more
about and found these things called
Place cells so what I'm plotting here is
each of these columns is a single neuron
and the mouse or rat I can't remember is
running around a square environment the
black lines are the path the rodent
traces out through time and you put a
red dot down every time you see this
individual neuron Spike and then the
bottom plot of this is just a smooth
version of that Spike rate so that
firing rate so what you can think of is
like the activity of a neuron and neural
network that's the analogy that people
usually draw and so these ones are
called play cells because they're
neurons that respond in a particular
position in space and in the 70s this
was like huge excitement you know people
have been studying mainly like sensory
systems and motor output and suddenly a
deep cognitive variable Place something
you never you don't have a GPS signal
there but somehow there's this like
signal for what looks like position in
the brain in very like understandable
ways
uh the next step in uh the biggest step
I guess in this chain of Discovery is uh
the moza lab which is a group in Norway
they uh second electron a different area
of the brain the Midland terrinal cortex
and so this is the hippocampal enterinal
system we're going to talk about and
they found this neuron called a grid
cell so again the same plot structure
that I'm showing here but instead these
neurons respond not in one position a
room but in a try like a hexagonal
lattice of positions in a root okay so
this uh these two I guess I'm showing to
you because they like really motivate
the underlying neural basis of this kind
of like uh spatial cognition and
embodying the structure of this space in
somewhere okay and it's very surprising
finding why why are neurons choosing to
represent things with this hexagonal
lattice it's like yeah
uh provoked a lot of research since and
broadly there's been like many more
discoveries in this area so uh there's
places I've talked to about grid cells
cells that respond based on the location
of not yourself but another animal uh
cells that respond when your head is
facing a particular direction cells that
respond to when you're a particular
assistance away from an object so like I
am one step south of an object that kind
of self
uh cells that respond to reward
positions cells respond to vectors to
boundaries those responsible for like
all sorts all kinds of structure that
this uh this this pair of brain
structures the hippocampus here this red
area and the enter anal cortex this blue
area here uh which is yeah it can served
across a lot of species are represented
um there's also finally one finding in
this that's fun is they didn't an fmri
experiment on London taxi cab drivers uh
and uh I don't know if you know this but
the London Pakistan drivers they do I
think all the knowledge uh which is a
two year long test where they have to
learn every street in London and the
idea is that the tests go something like
oh there's a traffic jam here a road
work here and I need to get from like
um Camden town down to Wandsworth in the
quickest way possible what route would
you go we have to tell you which route
they're going to be able to take it
through all the roads and like how they
would re-plan if they found a it's not
that those kind of things so it's like
intense are you see them like driving
around sometimes learning all of these
like Roots
um with little Maps they're being made a
little bit obsolete by uh Google Maps
but you know luckily they got them
before that uh this experiment was done
before that was true and so they've got
here is a measure of the size of your
hippocampus using fmri versus how long
you've been a taxi cab driver in months
and the claim is basically the longer
you're a taxi cab driver the bigger
you'll hit the campus the more you're
having to do this kind of spatial reason
so that's a big set of uh evidence that
these brain areas are doing something to
do with space but there's a lot of
evidence that's uh there's something
more than that something non-spatial
going on in these areas okay and we're
going to build these together to make
the broader Claim about this like
underlying structural inference and so
I'm going to talk through a couple of
those uh the first one is is a guy
called patient hm this is the most
studied uh patient in like medical
history he uh had epilepsy and to cure
interactional epilepsy you have to cut
out the brain region that's causing
these like seizure-like events in your
brain and in this case uh the escalator
is coming from the guys hippocampus so
they bilaterally lesions like cut out
both of the city of Kanpai and it turned
out that this guy then had terrible
Amnesia he never formed another memory
again and he could only recall memories
from a long time before the surgery
happened okay uh but he they were yeah
so experiments were showed a lot of
their stuff about how we understand uh
the neural basis of memory uh things
like he could learn to do motor tasks so
somehow the motor tasks are being done
for example you they gave him some very
difficult multiple coordination tasks
that people can't generally do they can
with a lot of practice and he got very
good at this eventually
um and was as good as other people at
learning to do that he had no
recollection of ever doing the task so
he'd go into the new task and be like
I've never seen this before I have no
idea what you're asking to do and they
do it amazing be like yeah so
um there's some evidence there that the
hippocampus is involved in least some
parts of memory there which seems a bit
separate to this stuff about space that
I've been talking to
uh second of these is uh imagining
things so this is actually a paper by
James who's uh before he was deep-minded
with a neuroscientist
um and here uh maybe you can't read that
I'll read somebody that
um you're asked to imagine uh you're
lying on a white sandy beach in a
beautiful tropical Bay and so the
control this bottom one says things like
this very hot and the Sun is beating
down on me the sand underneath me is all
almost unbearably hot I can hear the
sounds of small wavelets lapping on the
beach to see this gorgeous aquamarine
color you know like so a nice Lucid
description of
um this BTC whereas the person with a
hippocampal damage says as we're seeing
I can't really apart from just the sky I
can hear the sound of Seagulls Under the
Sea
um I can feel the grain of sand
underneath my fingers
and then like yeah the struggles are
basically really struggles to do this
imagine an imagination scenario some of
the things we need is like surprising so
uh the last of these is this uh
transitive inference task so Transit
inference a is greater than b b is
greater than C therefore a is greater
than C and the way they convert this
into a rodent experiment is you get
given two pots of food that have
different smells and your job is to go
to the pot of food you learn which part
of food has sorry which part with the
smell has for food and so these uh that
are colored by the two parts by their
smell A and B and the rodent has to
learn to go to a particular pot in this
case the one that smells like hey and
they do two of these they do a has the
food when it's presented in a pair with
B and B has the food when it's presented
in a pair with c and then they test what
does the mouth do when presented with A
and C a completely new situation and if
they have a hippocampus they'll go for a
over C they'll do transitive influence
if they don't have one they can't and so
there's a much more broad this is like
oh I've shown you how hippocampus is
used for this spatial stuff that people
have been excited about but there's also
all of this kind of relational stuff
imagining you situation some slightly
more complex story here
uh the last thing I'm going to do is how
the enter Rhino cortex as well so that's
where if you remember hippocampus was
these guys enter Rhino cortex was these
grid cells without enteronal cortex was
appearing to do some broader stuff as
well this is all motivation for the
models just trying to build all of these
things together
uh so in this one this is called the
stretchy Birds task okay so uh you put
people in an fmri machine and you make
them navigate but navigate in Bird space
and what Bird Space means is it's a
two-dimensional space of images and each
image is one of these birds and as you
vary along the X Dimension the bird's
legs get longer and shorter and there's
a vary along a y direction the bird's
neck gets longer and shorter okay and
the patients sit there or subjects sit
there and just watch the bird images
change so that it traces out some path
in 2D space but they never see the 2D
space they just see the images okay and
the claim is basically and then they're
asked to do some like navigational tasks
they're like oh you whenever you're in
this place in 2D space you show like
Santa Claus next to the bird and so the
participants have to pin that particular
bird image that particular place in 2D
spaces to the Santa Claus and you're
asked to like go and find the Santa
Claus again using some non-directional
controller and like navigate their way
back
and the claim is that these people use
grid cells so the enter Rhino cortex is
active in how these people are
navigating this abstract cognitive Bird
Space you know where you test that claim
is you you look at the fmri signal in
the enterinal cortex as the participants
head at some particular angle in Bird
Space
and because of the six-fold symmetry of
the hexagonal lattice you get this six
volt symmetric waving up and down of the
enterinal cortex activity as you head in
particular direction within 2D space it
was like evidence that this system is
being used not just for like navigation
and 2D space but any cognitive task with
some underlying structure that you can
extract you use it to do these tasks
significance the Birds space also been
to here yes yes
like variability uh people haven't done
that experiment but people uh have done
things like look at how grid cells rep
are they even done that
they've done things like 3D space but
not like cognitive 3D space they've done
like literally like make they don't in
bats they say collectors and bats to
make the bats fly around the room look
at how their grid cells respond yeah but
definitely uh
there I think they've done it ah they've
done it in
um sequence space so in this case you
hear a sequence of sounds with
hierarchical structure so it's like how
those months weeks days and meals
something like that so like weeks have a
periodic structure months have a period
of extra days have a period expect that
in meals on a periodic structure and so
you'll hear a sequence of sound with
exactly the same kind of structure as
that hierarchy of sequences and you look
at the representation in the enteral
cortex through fmri and use exactly the
same thing that the structure is all
represented in like that even more than
that you actually see in their adrenal
cortex a array of length scales so one
end of the anterior cortex you've got
very large landscale grid cells like
responding to large variations in Space
the other only are very small ones and
you see the same thing to do that
they're like meal cycle that Cycles a
lot more quicker is represented in one
end of the internal cord that's an fmri
and the month cycle is at the other end
of the scale in between so there's some
yeah evidence of that ended
all right uh so I've been talking about
MEC the medial interino cortex another
brain area that people don't look as
much as the LEC the lateral length
around our cortex but will then be
important for this model and basically
the the only that that you should be
aware of before we get to the model is
that it seems to represent very high
level the similarity structure in a
lateral and toronal cortex seems to be
like a very high level semantic one for
example you present some images and you
look at how you know the visual cortex
things are more similarly represented if
they look similar but by the time you
get to the lateral and to run a cortex
things look more similar based on their
usage for example like an ironing board
and an iron will be represented
similarly even though they look very
different because they're somehow like
semantic women
okay so that's the role that the LEC is
going to play in this model
uh so yeah basically the claim is uh
this is for more than just 2D space so
the neural implementation of this
cognitive map which is for not only 2D
space which this cartoon is supposed to
represent also things any other
structure so some structures like
transitive inference this one is faster
than that and it's faster than that or
family trees like this person my
mother's brother owner is there for my
uncle those kind of things these like
broader structural inferences that you
want to be able to use in many
situations so it's basically the same
problem
great that was a lot of Neuroscience
and now I'm going to get onto the model
that tries to summarize all of these
things and that's going to be the model
that will end up looking like a
transport
so
um yeah we basically want this
separation these diagrams here are
supposed to represent a particular
environment that you're wandering around
it has an underlying grid structure and
you see a set of stimuli at each point
on these grid which these little cartoon
bits and you want to try and create a
thing that separates out this like 2D
structural grid from the actual
experiences you're seeing and they're
mapping to the things I've been showing
you is that this grid grid like code is
actually the grid cells in the middle
enter anal cortex are somehow
abstracting the structure the lateral
lanternal cortex encoding these
semantically meaningful similarities
will be the objects that you're seeing
so it's just like this is what I'm
seeing in the world
and the combination of the two of them
will be the hippocampus
so yeah in more diagrams we've got G the
structural code the grid code in MEC and
LEC or someone asking a question
since morning so now it's lunchtime yeah
sorry I can't hear you if you're asking
a question
how do I mute someone if they're
maybe type it in the chat if there is
one
nice
um
so yeah we've got a hippocampus in the
middle which is going to be our binding
of the two of them together
okay
so I'm going to step through each of
these three parts on their own and how
they do the job that I assigned to them
uh and then uh come back together and
show the full model
so uh later on integrinal cortex encodes
what you're seeing so this is like the
these images or the houses we were
looking at before and that will just be
some Vector XT that's different so a
random Vector different for every single
uh the middle and Toronto cortex is the
one that tells you where you are in
space and it has a job of path
integrating okay so this means receiving
a sequence of actions that you've taken
in space for example I went north east
and south and tell you where in 2D space
that you are so somehow the bit that
embeds the structure of the world
and the way that we'll do that is this G
of T this Vector of activity is in its
brain area will be updated by a matrix
that depends on the actions you've taken
okay so if you step North you update the
representation with the step North
Matrix okay and those matrices are gonna
have to obey some rules for example if
you step North then Step South you
haven't moved and sort of Step North
Matrix instead of South Matrix actually
inverses of one another so that the
activity stays the same and represents
the structure of the world
okay so that's the world structure part
ly uh the memory because we have to
memorize which things we found at which
positions going to happen in the
hippocampus that's going to be through a
version of these things called the hot
field networks that you heard mentioned
in the last talk so this is like a
Content addressable memory and it's
biologically plausible with the claim uh
the way it works is you have a set of
activities P which are the activities of
all these neurons and when it receives
uh so just like recurrently updates
itself so there's some weight Matrix in
here W are some nonlinearity and you run
it for an entire and it just like
settled into some dynamical system it
settled into some attractive state
and the way you make a new memory is
through the weight Matrix okay so you
make it like a sum of outer products of
these Pi mu each Chi has some memory
some pattern that you want to record
okay uh and then it's yeah this is just
writing it in there the update pattern
is like that and the claim is basically
that if P the memory the the activity of
the neurons the hippocampal neurons is
close to some memory say chi mu then
this dot product will be much larger
than all of the other dot products with
all the other members so there's some
over all of them were basically
dominated by this one term Pioneer and
so your attractor network will basically
settle into that one plane
and maybe the preempt some of the stuff
that's kind of come later you can see
how this like similarity between points
is uh yeah Paradise similarity and then
adding some adding them up weighted by
this highway similarity is the bit
that's going to turn out looking a bit
like attention
um and so some of the cool things you
can do with these systems is like uh
here's a set of images that someone's
encoded in a hot field Network and then
someone's presented this image the
network and asked it to just run to its
like dynamical attractor uh Minima and
it recreates all of the memory that it's
got stored in it's sort of like
completes the rest of it
uh so that's our system
yeah
I heard that like this interpretation is
like the modern interpretation awkward
uh this one's actually uh which
interpretation sorry
oh yeah
uh yeah yeah it's only the the link to
Transformers will basically only be
through the pack there's classic coffee
on networks and then there's modern ones
that were within like 2016 and the link
between attention and modern is precise
the link with like classic is not as
good I mean you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
foreign
because then you have to do the
exponentiation thing
well maybe get to it later you can tell
me something yeah no no no no more
questions are good
we'll get well yeah maybe separate
energy function and I think the
exponential is in that event yeah
uh so that's basically how our system is
going to work but this Tom and
eichenbach machine that's what the name
of this thing is uh and so you the
patterns you want to store in the
hippocampus so these memories that we
want to embed are a combination of the
position and the input and like half of
employment space here if you then have
decided you want to end up in a
particular position you can recall the
stimulus that you saw there and uh
predict that as your life next
observation or vice versa if you like
see a new thing you can infer oh I path
integrated wrong I must actually beat it
you know
there's usually more than one thing in
the world that might be in different
positions
yeah that's the whole system does the
whole uh common I can bound machine
makes sense roughly what it's doing
okay cool uh and basically this last bit
is saying it's really good so uh what
I'm showing here is this is on the 2D
navigation task and it's right so it's a
big grid I think they use like an 11 by
11 or something and it's like wandering
around and have to predict what's going
to see in some new environment
and uh on here this is the number of
nodes in that graph that you've visited
and on the y-axis is how much you
correctly predict and each of these
lines is based on how many of those type
of environments I've seen before how
could we go into that and the basic
phenomena is showing is over time as you
see more and more of these environments
you learn to learn so you like learn the
structure of the world and eventually be
able to quickly generalize to the new
situation and predict what you're going
to see and there's scales not with like
the number of edges that you've visited
which would be the like learn everything
option you know prediction because if
you're trying to predict which state I'm
going to see given my currency an action
and in a dumb way you just need to see
all states in action so all edges uh but
this Wing is able to do it much more
clearly because it only needs to visit
all nodes and just memorize what is at
each position and you can see that it's
learning curve follows the number of
nodes visited
it's a thing wrong uh for Neuroscience
uh this is also exciting is that the
neural patterns of response in the brain
in these like model regions match the
ones observed in the brain so in the uh
hippocampal section you get Place
cell-like activities this is this
hexagon is the grid of the environment
that it's exploring and plotted is the
firing rate of that neuron whereas the
ones in the medial and terrinal cortex
show this grid-like firing pattern
yeah
this like exactly compare it operates on
like discrete spaces essentially yeah do
you have any thoughts about how that
transfers what anything those real world
thing do you think that we're just like
map Representatives into like a very
nicely discreet kind of space where we
think that when they click the more
complicated
yeah I imagine there's something more
complicated going on I guess this uh
so it's like a super no yeah maybe you
can make sure that you make arguments
that they as I was saying there's these
different modules that have cooperated
at different scales you can see this
already here like grid cells at one
scale Droid cells at another scale and
so you could imagine how that could be
useful for like uh one of them operates
in the highest level one of them
operates at the lowest level you know in
life yeah adaptable they seem to scale
up or down depending on your environment
and so like an adaptable set of length
scales that you can use so that's quite
speculative
okay sorry yeah to make sure I
understand if you go up
um okay one more yeah so you have your
what's the key and what's the value
um yeah so the
um and and how the networks are always
Auto instead of Petro Associated so how
are you the memories that we're gonna
put in so the patterns let's say kainu
is going to be some like outer product
of the position at a given time and the
uh
flattened
uh sorry yeah take the other product
though so every element in X can see
every element of G flatten those out and
let's go back to the government
does that make sense yeah sorry I should
put that on
yeah and then you do the same operation
except you flatten with an identity in
the let's say you're at a position you
want a pretty cool you're going to see
you set x to the identity you do this
operation that creates a very big Vector
from G you put that in and you let it
run at stagnantics and it recalls the
pattern and you like uh learn a network
that like traces out the X from them
and the figures you show if you go down
a bit yeah yeah the it's it's hard to
see but once on the x-axis and what's
like what are you training a popular
network with this
uh flattened out our product of the okay
yeah the the actual the training that's
going on is more in the structure of the
world now because it has to learn those
matrices all it gets told is which
action type it's taken and it has to
learn the fact that stepping East is the
opposite stepping West so all of the
learning of stuff is in those matrices
learning to get the right structure
there's also I mean because the the hot
fuel Network learning the Hot Wheel
networks like re-initialize every
environment and you're just like shoving
memories in so it's less like that's
less the bit of the screen it's causing
this certainly but it's not causing this
like shift up which is as training
progresses in many different
environments you get better at the task
because it's learning instruction with
us
and the link to this is all just modern
popular Networks
um the initial paper was actually
classic cocktail networks but yeah the
now now the new versions of our models
yeah right and then in so much as modern
home build networks equal the tension
but then you're okay and then you have
some there are some results looking at
activations
well these are recordings in the brain
these are no these are actually in the
intent so this is aim the left ones are
neurons in the G section in the middle
electronic cortex part of 10.
yeah
and we're going to get you my last
section is about how these 10 is like a
little bit so hopefully it will be clear
the Link's changes okay we're happy with
that though hopefully cool Tim is
approximately equal to transform yeah so
um you you seem to you you know all of
this uh but I guess my notation at least
we can clarify that uh you've got your
data which is maybe your like tokens
coming in and you've got your positional
embedding and the positional embedding
will play a very big role here that's
the E and together they make this Vector
H okay and these arrive over time yeah
and you've got your attention updates
that you see some similarity between the
key and the query and then you add up
weighted the values with those
similarities so we're all happy with
that
and here's the Stacked version
um so the basic intuition about how
these parts map onto each other is that
the G is the positioning coding as you
may be able to predict the x or the
input tokens uh this guy when you put in
the memory and you try and recall which
memory is most similar to that's the
attention part
um and uh maybe some yeah you attend you
compare the current GT to all of the
previous GTS and you recall the ones
with high similarity structure and
return the corresponding X
um
maybe some differences so I think I'm
going to go through this between how you
would maybe uh like the normal
Transformer and how to make it map onto
this are the following uh so the first
of these is the keys and the queries are
the same at all time points so there's
no difference in The Matrix that maps
from uh tokens to keys and tokens
queries same Matrix and it only depends
on the positional encoding
okay so you only recall memories based
on how similar their positions are
so yeah this is
Kia time Tau equals query time Tau
equals some Matrix applied only to the
positional embedding attention
uh then the values depend only on this X
part so it's some like factorization of
the two which is the value at turn
Towers like some value Matrix only apply
to that X part but the only bit you want
to play uh recall I guess uh is that
right that's right
and then it's a causal Transformer in
that you only do attention at things
that have arrived at time points in the
past
make sense
and finally the perhaps like weird and
interesting difference is that there's
this path integration going on in the
positional encodings so these e or the
equivalent of the grid cells the G from
the previous bit and they're going to be
updated through this Matrix that
depending on the actions you're taking
in the world
people uh yeah so that's basically the
correspondence I'm going to go through a
little bit about how the hot field
network is approximately like doing
attention over previous tokens
so yeah I was describing to you before
the classic Hot field network uh which
if you remove the nonlinearity looks
like this and the mapping I guess is
like the hippocampal activity the mem
the like current neural activity is the
query
uh the set of memories themselves are
the key you're doing this dot product to
get the current similarity between the
query and the key and then you're
summing them up weighted by that dot
product uh all of the memories they're
the values
so that's a simple version
uh but actually these Hot Wheel networks
are quite bad they like uh in some
senses they tend to fail they have a
like a low memory capacity for n-neurons
they have something they can only embed
like 0.14 n memories just like a big
result from statistical physics 80s
um but it's okay people have improved
this the reason that they're bad it
seems to be basically the overlap
between your query and the memories is
too big for two memory Too Many Memories
you know you basically like look too
similar to too many things so how do you
do that you like sharpen your similarity
function okay and the way we're going to
sharpen it is through this function and
this function is going to be soft so
it's going to be like oh how similar am
I to this particular pattern weighted uh
exponentiated and then over how simple
amount of all of the other ones that's
our new measure of similarity and that's
the minus sign of the modern hot film
yeah
um
and then you can see how this thing uh
yeah it's basically doing the attention
mechanism
um it and it's also
um biologically plausible
we'll quickly run through that is that
you have some set of activity PT this
like uh neural activity and you're going
to compare that to each Chi mu and
that's through these memory neurons so
there's a set of memory neurons one for
each pattern that you've memorized mu
and the weights to this memory neuron
will be at this Chi mu and then the
activity of this neuron will be this dot
product
and then you're going to do divisive
normalization to uh to run this
operation between these neurons so like
to make them compete with one another
and only recall the memories that are
most similar through the most activated
according to this like soft Max
operation and then they'll predict back
to the PT and produce the output by
summing up the memories weighted by this
thing times the chi mu which is the
weights so the weights out to the memory
neurons and back to the memory back to
their feet the canvas are both tiny
and so that's how you can like
biologically possibly Run This Modern
Hardware Network
and so sorry yeah
like do you attend over every memory
you've ever made probably not probably
not yeah
um I guess somehow you have to have
knowledge you know in this case it works
nicely because we like wipe this poor
agent's memory every time and only
memorize things from the environment and
so you need something that like Gates it
so that it only looks for things in the
current environment somehow uh uh how
that happens I'm not sure there are
claims that there's this like uh just
shift over time the claim is basically
that like somehow as time passes the
representation just slowly like rotate
or something and then they're also
embedding something like a Time
similarity as well because the closer in
time you are the more you're like in the
same rotated thing
um so maybe that's a mechanism to like
um you know pass a certain time you
don't recall things but the evidence and
debate a lot around that so yeah other
mechanisms like it I'm sure
maybe context is another one actually
well briefly talk about that you know if
you know you're in the same context and
you can send a signal like somehow in
the previous like work out what kind of
setting am I in you can send that signal
back and be like oh make sure you
attempt to these ones that are in the
same context
so yeah there we go uh Tim Transformer
that's the job it path integrates its
positional encodings which is kind of
fun uh it computes similarity using
these positional encodings uh and it
only compares to past memories but
otherwise it looks a bit like a
Transformer setup and here's the setup
we had our MEC LEC hippocampus and
placements
some yeah so here's a brief the last
thing I think I'm going to say is that
like
um
this extends tem nicely because it
allows it previously you have to do this
outer product and flatten that's a very
dimensionality is like terrible scaling
with like for example if you want to do
position what I saw and the context
signal something after like outer
product three vectors and flatten that
that's much much bigger you're scaling
like 10 cube right rather than uh what
you'd like to do which is like 3M and so
this uh version of tem with this new
modern hot field network does scale
nicely to adding a context input as just
another input in what was previously
this like modern hot film Network so
yeah there's some uh so yeah our
conclusions is there's like proved
somewhat interesting as a two-way
relationship uh from the AI to the neuro
side we use this new memory model This
Modern Hot Wheel Network that has uh all
of you know all of this bit is supposed
to be in the hippocampus whereas
previously we just had these like memory
bits in a classic Hot field now we can
hit the campus so it makes kind of
interesting predictions about different
place cell structures in the hippocampus
and they just sped up the code a lot
right
uh from the neural to AI maybe there's
some a few things that are slightly
different this like learnable recurrent
positioning coding so people do some of
this I think they get like positioning
coding as a learn RNN that updates them
but maybe this is like uh some
motivation to try for example they don't
know where the weight matrices and these
weight matrices are very biased towards
because they're invertible generally and
things like that they're very biased
towards representing these very clean
structures like 2D space so I mean uh
you know interesting building is like
one attention layer only and so like
somehow by using nice extra
representations making the task very
easy in terms of like processing X and
using the right positional encoding
you've got it to solve the task with one
of these also kind of nice and maybe
it's like a nice interpretation is that
you can go in and really probe what
these neurons are doing in this network
and really understand it you know we
know that the position encoding looks
like grid cells we have a very deep
understanding of why grid cells are a
useful thing to have if you're doing
this path integration so it's like uh
hopefully it helps like interpret all
these things oh yeah and if there was
time I was going to tell you all that
grid cells which are my hobby horse but
I don't think this time so I'll stop
that excellent
foreign
[Music]
because you because you've got
electrodes stuck in here right and they
generally have like the classic
measuring technique is a tetrade which
is for wife okay and they receive these
spikes which like electrical
fluctuations as a result of a neuron
firing and they can like triangulate
that that particular Spike they measured
because of the pattern of activity on
the four wires has to have only come
from one position so they can work out
which neuron sent that particular Spike
yeah but that's so there's a set of
neurons that have grid cell patterns uh
lots of neurons have patterns that are
just translated versions of one another
so the same grid like shifted in space
that's called the module and then there
are sets of modules which are the same
types of neurons that were the lattice
that's much bigger or much smaller and
in rats there's roughly seven so there's
a very surprising crystalline structure
of these seven modules within each
module each neuron is just translated
version of one area which uh yeah
there's a lot of theory work about why
that's a very sensible thing to do if
you want to do path integration at work
out where you are in the info based on
your like velocity signals
okay nice
this data could be said this was like
really fascinating about the friendly
thing is this
a product or a product of learning
um Evolution it's like it emerges like
uh 10 days after in a baby rats like
after being born
um so suddenly oh suddenly that
structure seems to be like uh very
biased to being created
um unclear you know we were talking
about how it's being co-opted to encode
other things
and uh so it's debatable how flexible it
is or how hard it is but it seemed you
know we're the fmri evidence suggests
that there's some like more flexibility
in the system unclear quite how it's
coding it but it'd be cool to get neural
recordings of it and see
let's figure another round
foreign